[Musik]
[Applaus]
er hat sich willkommen im tresor
werkschauen es ist einmal an was die
arbeit die abwehr truppe des
österreichischen bundesheeres so drauf
hat
sachen die kann man dann verzögerungen
bei der wz
htc hat jeder schon mal gehört aber der
eigentlich genau steht für atomare
biologische chemische abwerben
wir sitzen die soldaten und vor allem
auf die zivilbevölkerung vor atomaren
biologischen kampfstoff mallorca stoffen
cremigkeit wir sie allein reicht aber
nicht die kernkompetenz der waffen
gehabt und liegt in vier bereichen des
tc aufklärung das ist die
dekontamination der seite und berg und
brandschutz und kontaminierten gelände
die wasseraufbereitung ist so eine gute
truppe dass er weltweit gefragte
aussehen fonds ist das video mit dieser
eine katastrophenhilfe hat die
speziellen mit den fähigkeiten der
bietergruppe weltweit zum einsatz
gelangen kann was ja irgendwas für mich
zu tun oder keiner weise ein bisschen
genauer anschauen kann man das
angeforderte niedermoser hat sie was
einfallen lassen ein bisschen was leicht
dass man sauber oder 90 und das ist
unser aufklärungs pumpen mit den
selbstbehalt mitgeben
es hat sich am 30
[Musik]
was unseren vätern zug mit es ist quasi
bereit dass wir unseren aufklärungsflug
mitmachen kannst aussieht
[Applaus]
labor ist gesichert jetzt gibt es noch
proben zurücknehmen von den gefahren
schlossen den potenziellen investor
gefunden worden sind darunter wege
tänzen zu wenig
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so david der aufklärungszeit ist jetzt
erledigt und nach jeder aufklärung folgt
die dekontamination kräftige
unterstützung
sie wären damit nicht
die sowieso schädlich weil ihren
vorstellungen ist alles klar
schickes quantas dann tauschen gegen ein
richtiges kommt wenn jetzt zum retter
und schon wieder gibt der brandschutz
bekleidung
[Musik]
das ist dann unsere berge zugs kommunen
übergeben ich glaube dass man meister
wichtiger das gab mir das doch ist die
ganze nacht durch ko
und doch geben wird
hallo da ist die rettung
wie hält geweckt
[Musik]
so verwunderte jetzt wer hier den wert
um erfolgreich durchgesetzt
sie können es ja etwas tun und jetzt
kommen nur durch deren bezug zur
feuertaufe friedlich vorhaben von feuer
feuer
[Musik]
die abc abwehr truppe des inzwischen
bundesheer ist wenn der feind ein
unsichtbarer ist dann ist es nicht
besonders furchteinflößend er ist auch
sehr gefährlich
nur 15 die frauen und männer hinter mir
überhaupt nicht super ausgebildete
soldatinnen soldaten auf der einen seite
perfekt ausgebildete arbeitskräfte auf
der anderen und werden bei uns in
österreich sondern die seine
international im einsatz rund um den
globus hat beeindruckt in der gruppe und
ich glaube weil sie jetzt zusammen sind
aber gute gelegenheit einmal danke zu
sagen
[Musik]